hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching mind your decisions
the problem in today's video comes from
the american invitational mathematics
examination more commonly called the amy
the amy is the second test to qualify
for the us mathematical olympiad team
it's a three-hour test with 15 questions
and no calculators are allowed
the average score is around three
which is a mere 20 percent
it's a hard test even for the talented
students who qualify to take it
in this video i'm going to present
problem 14 from the 1987 test
the problem is to evaluate the following
fraction
every answer on the amy is an integer
from 0 to 999 inclusive
i thank anup from india for suggesting
this problem
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so how can we simplify this fraction
we'll get started by identifying a
pattern
every single parenthetical term in this
fraction is of the form x to the power
of 4 plus 324
furthermore we can factor 324
into 4 times 3 to the power of 4.
can we simplify this
i didn't know this trick but apparently
in mathematical competitions there's a
well-known identity called the sophie
germain identity it states that a to the
power of 4 plus 4 times b to the power 4
is equal to the following it's the
product of these two terms
it's a squared plus 2b squared minus 2ab
and the other term is a squared plus 2b
squared plus 2ab
so we'll apply this identity to x to the
4 plus 324
and we get the following
we can then simplify this by factoring
and we get the product of the following
binomials
we are now going to use this
simplification into every single term in
the fraction
let's get started with an example of 10
to the 4 plus
324
here we have x is equal to 10.
so we substitute that into our formula
and then simplify it
now let's take a look at 4 to the power
4 plus 324
here we have x is equal to 4
so we simplify it to get the following
so it seems like we haven't actually
made things any simpler we've actually
expanded out each term
but there's a cancellation that'll make
things simpler
so let's imagine we're just evaluating
this fraction
we simplified the numerator and the
denominator and now here's the trick the
first term in the numerator cancels out
with the second term in the denominator
so we have this fraction simplify to be
just the following fraction
this is going to be a little bit easier
to evaluate
now to get back to our original question
we're going to do a much more involved
simplification
so we're going to use the sophie germain
identity and use the formula presented
here to simplify every single term in
the numerator and every single term in
the denominator
now let's take a look if there's any
cancellation
the first term in the numerator cancels
out with the second term in the
denominator
then the second term in the numerator
cancels out with the third term in the
denominator and this pattern continues
so we're going to cancel out all of
these terms
and it goes all the way until the very
end
the only thing that survives is the very
last term in the numerator and the very
first term in the denominator
this kind of pattern is reminiscent of a
retracting telescope where the only
thing that survives is the first thing
and the very last thing
so our fraction simplifies to be just
the following
and it's an example of a telescoping
product
so now we just need to simplify this
fraction
well that's not too hard the numerator
is equal to 3730
and the denominator is equal to 10.
we divide and we get the answer of 373.
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on youtube
build confidence for students and
inspire mathematical discovery for
viewers around the world they have over
100 million views and the channel has
over 1 million subscribers please
subscribe for free to get the newest
videos and email me a puzzle or math
topic presh mindyourdecisions.com
if you so choose you can check out my
merchandise on teespring you can check
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon thanks for watching and thanks
for your support